somewhere in the near future physical
money will become like these relics of a
different age and will only be found in
places like this in other words hard
cash will disappear it will become
electronically transferred by things
like these so what's the rush to get rid
of cash and what's the cost let's face
it money is cumbersome for consumers and
banks need to mean the cash in Turpin
bills to transport them in armored
trucks Authority and secure votes you
need to sort it at the tail as well
operating in cash costs countries about
0.5 percent of their GDP every year but
cost isn't the only incentive to move
towards a cashless future demand is
rising primarily demand from young
generations we are looking for fast easy
to use means of payments digital
payments aren't just easy they're neat
it becomes easier for governments to
monitor tax evasion and fraud so we will
have less probity
having every single payment
automatically recorded is efficient but
there's a downside let's assume for
example that a country that used to be
democratic where people were not paying
too much attention but safeguarding
their privacy becomes undemocratic and
someone must to control cities and more
closely they will try to infer from what
you buy your critical leanings
potentially and rarest became just money
to what you're doing in ways that they
shouldn't be doing the ballot boxes are
kept locked and sealed living in a
democratic country doesn't mean you
shouldn't be concerned there are so
worried that private companies perhaps
might use this data in ways that are not
safe or that you might not like and for
a number of sectors knowing what to do
with your money is very important
electronic money trails can allow
governments and private companies to
access in harvest personal data but
there's another threat that's worrying
banks cyberattacks it was a high tech
bank robbery the long suffering a
massive hack attack involving 100
million capital and customers accounts
as their personal information stolen in
March 2019 Capital One Bank was hacked
solar hacker managed to steal away 106
million people's personal details in a
matter of days and that attack was
noticed just a few months after you can
see that a lot of companies are not very
well protected yet so against such that
pretty much every day we hear of data
breaches cyberattacks that are
successful it's much harder to prevent
an attack than to be on the hacker side
because you only need to succeed once as
a hacker once upon a time you have two
guys coming in Italy tell everyone to be
on the floor then we put the money in
the bag and then run away with the money
and you would get insurance against that
we knew what the which was nowadays with
cyberattacks they can happen anytime
they can take any form so it's very hard
to insure against still many countries
are fast moving towards a cashless
society in Sweden the number of retail
cash transactions per person has fallen
by 80% in the past ten years the trend
is even evident in far more cash loyal
societies China's digital payments rose
from 4% of all payments in 2012 to 34%
in 2017 the trend is inevitable
but a gradual transition is key it's
important that we have a sort of
controller hub as to how fast this
happens because if that's not the case
some people might be left behind some
people may find it harder to grasp how
much money they have without the
physical representation of it
not everyone knows how to use internet
banking technology and people living in
remote areas where internet cover is
patchy may find they have to drive for
miles for their basic needs and there's
another sector of society that relies
heavily on cash people living in the
street don't carry chemicals with him so
it would be very hard for them well
first of all to collect money and to pay
for things they will be among the people
who suffer the most from it going
cashless is just the latest evolution of
money in the modern economy but it
raises a fundamental question what is
the value of money if it doesn't
physically exist central bank's enact
monetary policy by exerting control over
the amount of money that is created and
that is in circulation and they can do
it because they are the only entities
that print and create money the purpose
of it is to control the amount of money
that is used by the entire economy in a
cashless society
obviously this becomes much harder
because money presumably can be created
by other entities and so central banks
are actually starting to realize this
especially after Facebook meant that the
announcements that they were going to
launch a digital currency it shows you
the extent to which central banks are
already thinking about the future of
money the move towards cashless
societies is well underway what
governments need to ensure that as cash
is phased out the vulnerable in society
aren't left behind
[Music]